first of all absolute pleasure because
you've helped put Lao cuisine on the map
I'm dying to get to understand for the
lad cuisine now our output not not too
sweet meet us and lots of stuff that we
get from the poorest river we also be
used more herbs Wow
what is he doing over there that crazy
man he's do fishing I mean not the
safest place to fish because really
strong water yes so that the fish more
tasty
well yeah they'll get fire against the
Korean Wow so by fighting the current
they get little bit more tastier or
tasty in mom why it's attack why more
exercise and so there's a big difference
between fish being caught down here it
was over the other side of the rapids
it's just so dangerous it's almost like
on the edge of that rock yeah we're
gonna have to attract me yeah it's
dangerous right
not really not really yeah I beg to
differ
Kearney Falls are the widest in the
world and 2.5 million gallons of water
crash over these rocks every second I
was hoping for lunch but this wasn't
what I had in mind
what then are we doing seriously
you sure this will take my weight joy
where are we going man local fishermen
mr. sin chan has been risking his life
sorry catching these prized me con fish
for decades
feedback
joy these fish better take delicious
this is crazy
traditional cast net fishing has been
practiced for thousands of years elbow
but I've just minutes to get the hang of
it
number hold happy ready this is not a
good idea try not to jump in the net yes
[Music]
[Music]
no I tell you what they make it look so
easy but there is nothing easy in this
that's an edgy place to fish it's the
force of that water inches away from you
and one slip when you're gone joy this
time we catch something pink oh Christ
we can guess here we go
Wow good job or we get some fish
but in it yeah nothing the cookie means
it we're catching fish here surely
nothing morning what I each put a lot of
fish there can usually only in the
morning see telling me it's not the
right time of day joy there's no joy in
this thankfully mr. sunshine takes pity
on me and kindly shares his morning
catch oh my god and what's that here yes
look at those beauties they're gorgeous
right let's get inside before you get
killed want to see more for my uncharted
adventures please click here to watch
more clips